[Music]
first of all I want to say thank you so
much for coming in today
I totally want to geek out about so many
things before we get started though the
only reason Collider gets to be at the
Toronto Film Festival is because of our
sponsors I want to give a huge thank you
to Nordstrom Canada for being awesome
thank you it's the only reason we get to
it's expensive to cover these festivals
and I want to say thanks I cannot wait
to see your movie I want to start with
that man I have so many questions I want
to drill on in but I guess I'm gonna do
the first thing which is we're at
Toronto what does it mean for both of
you to be part of the festival it's my
favorite place they have such amazing
movies here
I love Toronto I mean it's the first
Film Festival I ever came to with bail
and I've shot here as well and been here
for several movies and it's such a
privilege there's such a buzz here and
yeah it's so exciting to be premiering
I've been coming here since I was a kid
because my family had a place up near
North Bay and I it's like second home to
me so I not to mention the immortal
classic death to smoochy was shot in
Toronto and the Hulk as well so I've
lived here hung out here loved it
sure and the festival is great I agree
it's a very um there's goodwill at this
festival that's very sincere you
mentioned right I think right when the
camera started going but I have to say
if the I love The Illusionist just love
it it's one of those movies that just
love and if it comes on cable it I'm
compelled to finish it do were you
surprised this is not where I was gonna
go at all but are you surprised at that
movie because people seem to genuinely
like everyone I know loves that movie
it's like are you surprised that you've
done anything that people enjoyed yes I
am right that came out badly let me
rephrase no no I'm kidding I'm kidding
no you know you make you make things you
make things because they they speak to
you on some level you know or you
wouldn't do them and um but you never
know you never you you never know a
movie is many many many layers
and they all kind of have to like glue
together right for it to it's magic it's
an alchemy you never know you never
never never know and when you do a
tricky a tricky thing a period thing
about a magician the bet you don't know
you just don't know had the reason we
got talking about it is that film that
it was an oscar-nominated bit of
cinematography from like one of the
great cinematographers in the modern era
dick Pope who also shot every Mike Lee
film and and because of my experience on
the illusionist with him I begged him to
shoot motherless Brooklyn which he did
and it and it's it's like a masterwork
of photography I will say I would
imagine
I mean what's funny is so many people
don't realize when they're watching a
movie they just enjoy the movie but the
decisions you make on who you hire in
different departments for the crafts and
that the cinematographer even your
gaffer all these people it really
matters that crew course you know I've
said a lot of times that you like if a
person if a person goes hey I want to
make a movie about New York in the 50s
but not like little drawing room I want
to do it at scale big car chases I want
to be in the halls of power in jazz
clubs I want to have period music I want
to have all these things most people run
for the hills from the madman who's
gonna make life painful and the people
who don't the people who come toward
that and say we can do that I can shoot
that I can I can build the sets or find
the costumes or we create that music
like those are the people that end up
making you look sort of like you knew
what you were doing and we got an
extraordinary extraordinary group of
great artists to make this this sort of
epic of the of New York in the 50s look
great sure again so many questions I
guess I'm gonna Oh talk most people who
are gonna watch this interview will not
have seemed that the movie yet so talk a
little bit about
who you play and what attracted you to
this project yeah well I play Laura Rose
who when we first meet her she is being
followed by Andrews character Lionel and
so she sort of a figure of mystery
initially but you know what what really
drew me to her is she's an educated
woman she's a trained lawyer
she's a community activist and she sort
of is in between these two worlds of the
jazz scene in Harlem and also you know
Brooklyn in the 50s you know working
against racial discrimination in housing
all that is to say it's such a glorious
period and I love a period film myself
and you know I'd never done the 50s
before you know I've been a fan of
Edwards work for such a long time and
the script was just so rich and layered
and you know it's got that moody Irish
quality to it and for anybody who loves
New York I mean it's just really such a
love letter to the city so that drew me
to it so hopefully it will draw other
people as well I am like you I'm a huge
fan of your work in your I'm a huge fan
of your work and I'm just curious
it is so daunting to just direct a movie
it is daunting just to act in a movie
and then it's daunting to have your when
you're acting have some idiosyncratic
things to your character so you were
just like I want to do everything and
make it as humanly hard as possible yeah
it's like um it's like let's do the free
solo of films let's climb without a rope
the hardest possible mountain face what
I'm kidding you know it's it's um
remember that remember that Anthony
Hopkins Alec Baldwin movie the edge yes
great really good movie David Mamet
script and yeah anyway yeah there's the
thing where Anthony Hopkins says he has
the little book of survival in the
wilderness and he says like what one
person has done another can do I always
remembered that line and I think it's
kind of true like like you know if you
if you make films and you have something
in your head that you
feel deeply but it feels ambitious you
know I look at you know Orson Welles
made Citizen Kane and he plays a man
from 25 to his death and it's great
movie like and um and Warren Beatty made
Reds you know this three hour and
fifteen minute film about about American
socialists and it's really like one of
the great it's one of the great films of
the modern era and he wrote it and
produced it and directed it and started
it and people told him he was out of his
effing mind like they said nobody wants
to watch that movie and it's one of the
all-time greats and I I think there are
these examples of people you know Clint
Eastwood and Unforgiven and you know
Kevin Costner Dances with Wolves I I do
think I do think like sometimes when
someone feels a story very deeply and
they think they understand it you you
you it's a big swing but you take it and
you kind of go people have done this
before I can do this you know completely
I'm always obsessed if you don't mind
I'm just with the editing process
because it's the final rewrite I'm
curious you get in the editing room you
see your all your footage what's the
thing that you're most excited about and
what's the thing that you are freaking
out about I'm interested to you yeah I
call it it's the suicide watch a period
of making a film I think that one of the
things that was very clear to me even
while shooting it but certainly when we
looked at the big raw ungainly thing is
that the cast in this movie was just
like career-best you know what I mean it
was it was a cast of really really
terrific actors and it wasn't even that
there was a false note or a problem or
anything it was like in many ways it was
also the biggest problem like how are we
how are we gonna cut anything and these
people are so good like there there's
they were so compelling so great with
the language
and so I felt great about the cast great
about the performances I felt the
shaping you know with the story like
this when there's a mystery involved
it's you're always trying to learn how
much information the audience needs and
what level of confusion is a good level
of confusion you don't want people ahead
of a movie but you don't want them
falling out of it you want them confused
but you have to make sure the emotional
strains of the movie are carrying them
through that confusion you know
completely man I so I always ask this
again I apologize it's directing
question but uh how long was your first
cut compared to the finished film like a
cut you were happy with there were
versions of the movie that could have
been you know over two and a half hours
to two hours you know sure I think we
knew but but you know ultimately we have
a long credit role because there's so
much music in the movie the mood but the
movies the movies about two hours and 17
minutes long it's shorter than star is
born people in games like three hours
and 15 chapter two is 245 or two this is
much shorter than that by the way I
think about listen no no people you know
what you know it's a big lie I really
mean it especially in the era of Netflix
and binge TV and everything but one of
the I think one of the biggest
disservice is that critics do really is
they've watched too many films and
they're often tired of films they have
they've actually lost what real
audiences have which is the the fact
that it's it's pleasure to go sit in the
cinema and audiences like to sit in
movies it audiences don't care about the
length of movies that they they like to
sit in a movie that's taking them away
if it if it transports them and carries
them away I mean you look at if you look
at the running times of the greatest
films ever made though the best films
that won Best Picture nominated for Best
Picture
they're abundantly over two and a half
hours
and yet and yet critics will focus on
these things say I always say to people
like no like you can have a 90 minute
movie that feels too long and you can
have you know reds or Lawrence of Arabia
or Out of Africa or the Godfather movies
that are over three hours that you could
sit in for another hour long and I think
I think there's a tear yeah and there's
a terrible underestimation I think
critics will will underestimation as
they are and the truth is that's just
not the case well the thing that I found
in I think that the problem nowadays is
so many movies have been made that say
you make a 90 minute movie or a two hour
movie it's you you're following the
three-act structure and it's almost it's
very difficult to flip something on the
audience that they haven't seen before
what a longer movie allows is from where
secondary characters more plot more
availability to twist things that you've
never done before because you have more
time to tell your story yeah and the
character development and the language
in this is so rich as well you know
everybody speaks with that New York kind
of punchy energy and you know for me
especially I mean I haven't seen it a
couple of times when I'm in the editing
sort of process to see it also with the
music that really carries you you know
and the music is so evocative of the
period you know and you know Thom
Yorke's music as well you know so it's
it it really kind of gives you that sort
of epic flow to it for each of you I'm
almost out of time so I'm just gonna ask
there's I would imagine making this with
something you'll never forget if you
could each share a story from like a day
of filming that you're like you know
something that like something really
memorable if you don't mind or something
that really stands out in your brain Wow
I mean you know there was so many
memorable moments probably a really sort
of fun one for me was where we got to
kind of do a bit of action you know not
to spoil too much but towards the end of
the film laura has this like one moment
where she gets to kind of like really
like sock it to one of the back of my
life
and and I think you know cuz there's
there's a romance and there's a mood and
there's a lot of language in the film
but this light was just like a purely
physical kind of area down very
Hitchcockian fight on a fire escape yeah
yeah and that was that was a really fun
kind of and very different to the energy
of the rest of the film so let's say
Gugu can throw a potted plant special
found objects never seen aerial street
throw a heavy bit of pottery like Guzzi
does that would that that day was one of
my nightmares so actually I was sick
that was pure I was very mixed and and
we were shooting an incredibly
complicated action and visual effects
sequence so I'm glad you were having fun
i I had many ma you know we we filmed at
one point we we had a day where we
filmed in Washington Square Park in the
village we were about two blocks from my
house we're about three blocks from
Willem Dafoe's apartment and and we were
literally around the corner from Alec
Baldwin's apartment and we were all
working and Alec kind of came over to me
and goes if if we could just do it like
this I'd really enjoy this job you know
like like it was it was really it was it
was it was it was great it's New York
City is it's challenging it
um it it tries to break you because it's
a complexity but when you're when you're
when you're working and flowing within
it and the magic is happening you you
feel it it's a it's very special to
shoot films in New York because you also
get to go on a detective hunt of your
own to find these pockets of it that
still have this old world magic and and
I think I think I think people are
telling people are very clearly enjoying
the drift through this the world of this
movie and it's nice honestly can't wait
I have to stop with you and I really I
hope I get to talk to you again about
the film after I've seen it thank you so
much for coming by
absolutely